get ready to be wowed because Disney has
really hit the ball out of the park with
Beauty and the Beast their latest
live-action take on one of their
Animated Classics stepping into the role
of Belle is Emma Watson who gives a
lively performance that's an appealing
blend of warmth intelligence and
independence Watson of course already
has one iconic role under her belt
thanks to Harry Potter movies first buy
so beautifully updating and bringing one
of Disney's premier animated princesses
to life on the big screen
Watson has ensured herself another role
for which shall be fondly remembered for
many years to come since making his name
in Downton Abbey Dan Stevens has been
doing a great job avoiding posh pigeon
holes by keeping his career nice and
varied and as the beef he puts in a
suitably gruff and witty turn that's
really enjoyable to watch Luke Evans is
phenomenal as the uber arrogant Gaston
in fact he's so good it feels like he
was born to play this role and really
he's the absolute standout in the cast
for me like Josh GAD who played the foo
Evan to the background in musical
theater and they both get to put that to
good use here however unlike GAD evans
hasn't really been should too far before
into comedic territory but he absolutely
crushes it in Beauty and the Beast
showing his extremely adept in the
comedy department as Mithu Josh GAD who
previously gave voice to frozen's Olaf
works incredibly well with Evans adding
lots of humor and lovely improvised
moments to the film Ian McKellen is
simply perfect as cogs work and they may
be smaller roles that I love Audra
McDonald as God Rob Stanley Tucci's
cadenza and Gugu and battle as Polly met
Emma Thompson and Ewan McGregor has
tough acts to follow taking on the roles
of mrs. Potts and Lumia made famous by
Angela Lansbury and Jerry Orbach both of
them put their own spins on the role
adding some delicious touches and I
enjoyed both their performances so these
will still always be Lansbury in all
Beck's roles for me and while I wasn't
especially keen on lace and Max cake on
ship in the trailers I found it worked
much better in the actual film though I
do still prefer Bradley Pierce's
original chip Dreamgirls directed or
Condon whose co-writer Stephen Chbosky
and Evans Billy a topless and
cinematographer Tobias le Fleur have put
a delightfully fresh perspective on the
classic animations while managing to
keep alive so much of what fans love
about the original they've done
brilliantly fleshing out many of the
characters giving them more depth and
making their actions more believable
as well as adding more realistic
elements to the plot and ironing out
some inconsistencies in the animated
feature they've also included a couple
of little meta moments with a film
lovingly poke fun at itself and though
there's a rare moment that doesn't feel
quite as natural or smoothly executed as
the rest for instance when Belle meets
Lumiere they're so few and far between
there of no real consequence as for Alan
Menken and Howard Ashman genius
soundtrack from the animation that plays
an equally prominent part in this
live-action version in fact it's
fantastic to hear such wonderful new
performances of those much-loved tunes
including be our guest
Gaston Belle and Beauty and the Beast as
well as making a few lyrical and musical
changes to some of the original songs
Menken and Tim Rice have also penned
three new songs my favorite of which is
evermore sung by Dan Stevens speaking of
the movie song and dance numbers which
are really charming I've got to give
props to choreographer and Steven last
for his work which channels the
animations influences including full-on
Busby Berkeley as well as adding new
inspirations such as a touch of Seven
Brides for Seven Brothers designer
Jacqueline Duran is to be congratulated
for her work in the costume department
and production designer Sarah Greenwood
set decorator Katie Spencer and
supervising art director na Maroni have
outdone themselves bringing to life the
world of Beauty and the Beast
including Belle village and the beast
castle the castle in particular is truly
impressive with incredibly ornate
interiors and exteriors that seem to
grow and subtly change over the course
of the film's two hours and along with
the movie's VFX team they've done an
amazing job creating characters such as
Lumiere and Cogsworth the attention to
detail that's gone into the design of
these characters is striking with
elements from their human forms
influencing delicous objects and my
absolute favorite disease is Garda Robb
who is a triumph of imagination to sum
up Beauty and the Beast is an enchanting
take on Disney's much-loved animated
classic director Bill Condon and his
cast and crew have taken what was great
about the original and built on that in
new and satisfying ways while still
including plenty of Easter eggs and nods
to the original for die-hard fans the
production design and VFX are
jaw-dropping and the costume
cinematography and song and dance
numbers of gorgeous
basically it's an absolutely magical
movie that put a huge smile on my face
right from the start she also managed to
bring us here to my eye and I cannot
wait to watch it again now are you
looking forward
- about the live-action Beauty and the
Beast or if you've seen it what did you
think of it and who do you think is
going to be your favorite characters and
why let me know in the comments below
I've got more Beauty and the Beast
videos on the way including cool secrets
about the making of the movie so do
subscribe and turn on your notifications
for flicks in the city to make sure you
catch all my latest videos and you can
tap or click the screen here to check
out more videos you might like thanks
for watching and see you next time
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers